[Musik]
unser erfolg und unser reichtum sind
nicht das resultat einer einzelnen
handlung
sie sind abhängig von etwas viel
größerem von einstellungen und werten
und diese werden auch von unseren
glauben geprägt
wie sind wir gut vor gott
die reformatoren haben diese frage vor
500 jahren neu beantwortet sie haben die
schweiz gespalten und die schweizer
wirtschaft die moderne wirtschaftlich
von der reformierten entwickelt wurde
wenn man konversionsrate und karte wo
die wirtschaft entwickelt beieinander
legten deckte das
die katholikin interessieren sich lange
nicht für wirtschaftlichen fortschritt
ihre aufholjagd kommt spät aber
eindrücklich
[Musik]
schichtarbeit bei da viele wo heute
dichtungen für konsumgüter produziert
werden prallten in den werkhallen einst
zwei unterschiedliche weltbilder
aufeinander
vor 100 jahren steht das unternehmen im
katholischen uri wegen misswirtschaft
vor dem ruin
ein reformierter aus dem aargau kommt zu
hilfe
stellt es neu aufkauft es adolf dudley
der reformierte das bringt neue ideen
ins katholische altdorf neue
einstellungen neue werte
dort will er als protestant natürlich
ganz andere weltsicht das toll brothers
so damaliger kartoffel sie jeder
fortschritt glaubt und der möglichkeit
uns klar ist im werdegang vor dem
technologisch vom technischen
fortschritt wirtschaftliche profit
schlagen und alle stände wo ich kann der
niveau immer noch sehr
landwirtschaftlich fragt sich wo sehr
konservativ und katholisch und dass ich
sicher sehr benutzerfreundliche
situation sie die einheimischen
katholiken glauben noch nicht an den
industriellen fortschritt die
verantwortlichen der firma agieren
sorglos über schulden sich es sind
verwalter
[Musik]
adolf wieder dagegen ist ein pionier
er baut den krisenzeiten aus sucht neue
wege geht unternehmerische risiken ein
und stößt zunächst auf skepsis
auch privat als er 1924 die tochter des
katholischen land am ans heiraten will
katholische pfarrer von aadorf ein paar
ziele für die mission führt hochverdient
mit welcher zur verfügung stelle
darum hätte autostadt wieder und
sinnlichen ergaben waren wir es die
kliniker vielen im dorf und am
museumsufer donnerstag wieder wird seine
sicht der welt etablieren und
fortschritt in den kanton bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie sind wir gut vor gott
die reformatoren wie ver neue antworten
sie bekämpften den alten glauben wonach
nur gut ist wer sich aus den geschäften
der welt zurückzieht wer betet wer
applus bezahlt
martin luther sagt der mensch könne ohne
umweg über die kirche gut sein vor gott
das heißt aber auch er ist selbst
verantwortlich dafür
ulrich zwingli sagt müssiggang sei kein
dienst an gott
hingegen können arbeit etwas gutes sein
ja etwas göttliches
[Musik]
johannes calvin sagt hingabe im beruf
sei ein zeichen von göttlichem
wohlgefallen
[Musik]
es sind neue antworten die entscheidend
dafür sind wie die menschen denken wie
sie reden wie sie handeln
genf kathedral sepia wirkungsstätte
calvins was er und die reformatoren vor
ihm von der kanzel predigen ist gegen
die normen ihrer zeit sie verändern die
einstellung der menschen zur arbeit
fundamental
sie stelle ganz klar fest dass der
einfach christ durch seine tägliche
arbeit als handwerker aus kleinbetrieben
genauso gut es gottgefälliges leben
führt wiener in einer liga mit innerer
herrschaftliche tätigkeit oder
geistliche mit seiner sales
heute definieren wir uns maßgeblich über
unsere arbeit wer nicht arbeitet ist am
rand der gesellschaft vor der
reformation braucht es diese
randständigen geradezu ihnen geld zu
geben gilt als gute tat vor gott meine
mitarbeiter rom wo aber nicht mit mit
guter arbeit verdiene sondern mit button
das wird ja radikal diskreditiert das
ist stillos sich vor der reformatoren
überhaupt nimmt rinder liegt das volumen
oder mit almosen und mit aller fürsorge
unterstützt werde
wo unverschuldet in armut geraten aber
noch und die schaffe schaffe und so
selber verdienen
neue ideen mit sprengkraft sie spalten
die schweiz vor allem städtische gebiete
nehmen die reformation an
zürich basel bern genf
tiefe gräben ziehen sich durch land und
bevölkerung
appenzell wird in zwei welten geteilt in
das katholische inneren und das
reformierte ausserrhoden
hier liegt können
peter herrsche ist tief in beide welten
an getaucht er ist pensionierter
geschichts professor der universität
bern und katholisch
[Musik]
solche fensterreihen sieht man im
reformierten außer roten häufig gleich
nebenan im katholischen in ruden gibt es
sie nicht
es sind fenster zu weg kellern zu
kleinen aber wichtigen keimzellen des
fortschritts
der webstuhl in eine wanze das wohnhaus
gehört zu den letzten die noch an ihrem
ursprünglichen ort stehen und das hat
mir bei ihm war der sturm der große rote
das ist hoch innovativ thema versucht
der maschine zu verbessern mache dass
dies nicht mehr produzieren leinwand
tücher aus solchen kellern sind ab dem
siebzehnten jahrhundert weit herum
gefragt gezielt investieren die familien
ihre gewinne wieder bauen ein
wirtschaftliches fundament auf sie
suchen ihr heil in der arbeit
damit unterscheiden sie sich fundamental
von den menschen im katholischen inneren
nicht der wirtschaftliche erfolg ist
dort der heilsbringer sondern die kirche
[Musik]
eine rote hai tim 700 sage und schreibe
vier klöster grad da ich bin mir
bevölkerung also 2000 geworden ist das
große ganz verrückt und man weiß ja dass
die idealen helfer teilweise aber
natürlich los der gebaut der regulation
des stütz- finanziell und glüht selber
hat sehr viel geld wirklich löste
spendet also das geld kann der kanal
geleitet wurde wer in den jahrhunderten
nach der reformation vom ausserrhoden
über die grenze nach innen geht lernt
dort die andere welt kennen
das legen reiseberichte aus dem 18
jahrhundert mal reisende bemerkten auf
anhieb wenn sie in ruden erreichen
devisen chaman sehr schlecht bestellt
unbesorgt die wenigen häuser am wege
sind kleiner ärmlicher und überall
vermisst man die ordnung dem fleiß und
den wohlstand welche sich in
ausserrhoden überall zeigen
was sie diese bricht aus dort ist dass
der innere oder cng ist irgendwo
ebenfalls opfer sondern schafft wer die
natur und sogar ich hoffe dass er nie
haben ist das ist immer ein höherer wert
als viel geld die landwirtschaft bleibt
nach der reformation der haupt
wirtschaftszweig handwerk die ausnahme
die beiden appenzell stehen sinnbildlich
für die schweiz nach der reformation
die einen wollen technischen fortschritt
die anderen das bewährte vorerst
in solothurn verrichten katholische
bauernfamilien strikt arbeiten um etwas
zusätzliches geld zu verdienen
der obrigkeit ist dies ein dorn im auge
in einem erlass animiert sie die
solothurner bauern feldarbeit um den
tableaus oder verdienen weiß zu
übernehmen
denn nur die landwirtschaft sei eine so
räumlich und gottgefällige arbeit nach
kräften sucht die regierung einen weg
wie das erschlichene viele listen
moderiert werden könnte
[Musik]
nicht im weg keller wollen die
katholiken ihrer zeit verbringen sondern
im austausch mit gott der auffahrt zum
riedberg münster hatte ursprünglich
einen ganz praktischen sinn
man bittet gott um das richtige wetter
für die ernte
denn ernteausfälle sind für sie die von
der landwirtschaft leben eine
katastrophe
[Musik]
die prozession ist aber auch ausdruck
davon dass die katholiken die neuen
ideen der reformatoren strikt ablehnen
[Musik]
weiter widerstand leisten
das wäre natürlich das führt arbeit
braucht desto weniger ausgeprägt übrig
die katholische obrigkeit gewährt ihrem
volk allemal genügend zeit im
siebzehnten jahrhundert haben die
katholiken in der schweiz bis zu 70
feiertag
zählt man die sonntag dazu ist in guten
jahren jeder dritte tag arbeitsfrei
anders die reformierten die gemäßigten
unter ihnen haben 25 feiertage die
radikaleren etwa die calvinisten gerade
noch 5 bis 7
[Musik]
viel zeit für gott heißt weniger zeit
für die arbeit man könnte
gemeinschaftserlebnisse dieser art als
rückständig abtun
es gibt eine zweite sichtweise die
katholiken nehmen nur vorweg wonach sich
in der heutigen leistungsgesellschaft
viele sehen
wenn ihr so prozession vom mögliche und
nötige erschien egal ob denken natürlich
bestimmt wird schrieb der akteure
profane prozesse und hat der user
freunden in der volkskunde das zum
beispiel bei umzug bevor der lenker
ziemlich genaue kopie wo der front
lehren aus prozession bestimmt die zu
kommen muss sie haben also da werde es
in der eu katholiken
natürlich geben zu erkennen
[Musik]
gemeinschaft und muße in einer welt die
individuellen erfolg belohnt und die
ständigen fortschritt verlangt sehnen
sich die menschen in beromünster nach
erfahrungen die nicht messbar sind
bedeutet trainergespann trier unterwegs
ist die tradition fort beziehungen
angefangen die partie doch nicht so
heftig wie vielleicht andere arbeitet
mit dem zweiten stock ist am morgen
morgen von schloss linderhof
sonnenaufgang im hintergrund getreten
musik
daher spiele halt machen dass er das ist
einfach schön menschen dienst ist
gottesdienst wurde das für mich wichtig
gesellschaft mit dem lüd im dorf noch um
zusammen
jeder hat sie in ihre eigene tradition
oder unter militärs mit am tisch und das
gefallen ist
[Musik]
was den menschen heute wichtig ist
wollten die katholiken schon nach der
reformation unbedingt bewahren also
vergleich zur ewigkeit dieser sei
hierfür der ganze unterricht dürfe man
muss einfach sehen was unterhalb für die
ermittler aber nicht mehr per se der
rest haben wir den hebel zum bistro für
süchtige religiöse aktivität der beruf
und deshalb macht
[Musik]
die reformation teilt nicht nur die
schweiz in zwei glaubens räume sie
entzweit ganz europa der streit darüber
wer den wahren glauben hat wird mit
aller härte ausgetragen
die bartholomäusnacht 1572 in paris ein
massaker an anhängern der reformation
sie werden ermordet im ganzen land
verfolgt
[Musik]
wer kann flieht ins ausland tausende
dieser hugenotten finden aufnahme in
reformierten schweizer gebieten nicht
nur aus frankreich kommen sie sondern
auch aus italien
[Musik]
sie bringen ihre religiösen
überzeugungen mit verstecken auf der
flucht unter ihren perücken kleinst
bibeln wie das reformations museum in
genf zeigen und sie bringen ihre
rechnungsbücher und geschäftsbeziehungen
mit denn es fliehen jene die es sich
leisten können darunter händler
kaufleute gewerbetreibende
wer erfolg hat darf bleiben erst einmal
bringen sind die produktwelt schweizer
industrie groß gemacht hat
textilindustrie und uhrenindustrie das
ist ja synonym der quasi zur
schweizerischen vlies und schweizerische
arbeitsamt und und und andere sitzt sehr
viel kapital natürlich hat er mit island
wo finanzsektor hilft mit aufbau die
gern für sie häufig machen
sie verbinden also der handel mit dem
finanzdienstleistungssektor show im
siebzehnten 1800 und die kapitalien sie
nicht zuletzt auch gut die voraussetzung
für den aufbau von der fabrik industrie
im 19 jahrhundert inclusive der
geschäftsbeziehung was eine
exportorientierte wirtschaft mit sich
bringt wenn hugenotten in den städten
von zünften abgelehnt werden weichen sie
aufs land aus oder auf andere produkte
so verwandeln sie vermeintliche
nachteile in vorteil
ein beispiel calvin verbietet es in genf
reichtum zur schau zu stellen zum
beispiel schmuck zu tragen also verlegen
sich hugenottische goldschmiede auf die
uhrmacherei daraus entstehen später
uhrenmanufakturen die bis heute
existieren
mir ist das analog schuss gewitter
industrie handelt wo immer für den
export dank dass sie quasi ein export
tradition auf der schweizerische bilder
macht des spiels lief für die wahl
absolvieren oder hergestellt werden das
heißt es ist vorfall ein industrie der
warenproduktion wofür die großen fische
zentren in europa weg sei die große
metropole london paris produziert das
heißt es ist die exportorientierung vor
der schweizer industrie in 19 der 20 wtb
zieht fort spuren die
glaubensflüchtlinge bringen fortschritt
in die reformierte schweiz machen die
reicher und sie gründen traditionsreiche
firmen im neunzehnten jahrhundert etwa
die schokoladenfabrik sicher
[Musik]
bei den katholiken ist der reichtum ganz
anders gelagert er gehört den
kirchlichen institutionen
diese lassen wahre kunstwerke bauen wie
die stiftskirche beromünster
[Musik]
das geld für die kostbarkeiten um die
sich heute ein stift verwalter kümmert
kommt von den gläubigen
sie leisten applus sie stiften um gut zu
sein vor gott um das seelenheil zu
erlangen
der prunk ist eine entschädigung für das
düstere diesseits und ein vorgeschmack
auf das herrliche jenseits für mich
seine psp spiels erzählen oder steve
nash am hut mit investor bei meister st
weil man denkt so
der oder die verstorbene schneider vom
weg für das hat praktisch jeder ist im
testament verlangt wie durch oberklasse
die hand unter der dusche von steve
messe laser ich habe mal versucht das
ganz katholische europa die auf 100
millionen steve messer ist natürlich das
risikokapital von der kripo anderem ein
ende bereitet
[Musik]
so haben wir jetzt gold und
silberschmiedekunst gerade für mich ist
er als coach bis büro sakraler
verschwendet das gegenbeispiel ist
calvin ist der etl ist sogar noch nicht
klar
also alles möglichst einfach
wohingegen das katholische geld fließt
entstehen prachtvolle kunstwerke malerei
kirchenmusik dafür fehlt es anderswo
der wirtschaftliche rückstand wird
größer mit allen mitteln und zur
verteilung die moderne form zum beispiel
textilmanufaktur oder fabrikation aus
der manufaktur die sind auch public
entstanden als man das verfolgen von 710
grund noch dieses trends gestattet es
geht praktisch um einen seite honda bis
mitte des 20
krieg katholische unternehmen zwar
entstehen auch auf katholischen gebiet
formen von heimarbeit doch es sind oft
günstige zulieferer für reformierte
unternehmer insbesondere stadtrats danke
dass sie den industrie abfall anfallen
wo der nachher normal gearbeitet werden
für das normal stoff für hersteller und
heimarbeiter mit services beschäftigen
weil quasi vergütet galaxy für die
zürcher und anderen unternehmen
gearbeitet entry billigen gebiet wurden
in der innerschweiz vorhandenes lage und
ihre arbeiter arbeiten verrichten
wesentlich mehr wertschöpfung generieren
[Musik]
nur ein berufszweig bringt es in
katholischen gebieten neben der kirche
zu reichtum dir eisläuferin schweizer
söldner kämpfen auf europas kriegs
feldern für fremde herrscher ein
geschäft das sehr viel geld ins land
bringt
die große profiteure sie sicher die
sollte unternehmer wo die kompanien und
ihre gemeinden organisiert soldaten
erwerben geringer ist sicher
sie kommen vor deiner söldner
selbstläufer wie man muss sagen
sicherlich 1800 seit
wirtschaftsgeschichte ist sie komme auf
einen einfachen soldaten dann geschafft
lassen gladbacher als werden heime
belieben und hatte sich als tagelöhner
verdient
[Musik]
zwingli ist gegen die reis läuft er
findet es unmoralisch für geld in fremde
kriege zu ziehen
in reformierten gebieten wird dass
söldner wesen stark eingeschränkt
das katholische in davos in
konfessionell gespaltenen glarus hier
zeigt der freuler palast vom
einträglichen geschäft
sollte herr caspar freuler hat ihn 1642
bauen lassen
prunkvoll wie eine kirche
[Musik]
solches gold findet man in glarus
reformierten gemeinden nicht sie müssen
neue einkommensquellen suchen die macht
der kirche ist seit der reformation
begrenzt so öffnen sich neue freiräume
zum denken
zum fortschritt wirtschaftshistoriker
tobias straumann besucht den verwalter
des lake areals in die s-bahn
hier stand einst eine textilfirma die zu
den größten europas gehört den boden zum
sogenannten klarner wirtschaftswunder
liegt ein reformierter pfarrer willy
kanis am montag hoch muss zürich
hightech-geräte kaiser und der ex agent
jahr wurde und dank heute da
bis entwickler und hätte auch die
technik von bonbons barack obama mit
braucht das update und das ist relativ
schnell gegangen das den aufbau wurde
zwölfter unter den über das gemacht
haben und glied auf abend in der
heimischen liga entwickelt
[Musik]
der boden ist gelegt es gibt zwar
rückschläge aber die erfolgsgeschichte
in glarus ist weit über die
landesgrenzen hinaus beispielhaft ist er
also noch bevor mir fabrik gebaut das
zentrum wollverarbeitung sie und wo der
in die industrielle revolution wird sehr
schnell die umstellung der fabrik
gegründet und das ist unglaublich wie
schnell sich das entwickelt hat und klar
russischen der schweiz aber auch
europaweit als für einige wirklich
größte dichter fabriken
egal ob sie sind das einzige ort
[Musik]
die planer spuren nicht nur
wirtschaftlich vor sondern auch
gesellschaftlich als erste schreiben sie
den arbeitnehmerschutz ins gesetz so
viel beschäftigt die combo sektor dass
die mädels klein und den dialog sie sind
relativ frühe tor das beschränkt wurde
deswegen das arbeitsverhältnis
verbessert worden sind oder später auch
zu sechs gesehen früher als erste
kontrollen vor der fabrik der wille zum
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt hat aus
armen klarer gegenden reiche gemacht
willen der fabrik herrn zeugen bis heute
davon
[Musik]
im katholischen teil des kantons sind
industriebetriebe damals die ausnahme
hier bleibt dass söldner wiesen dominant
horizont von den akteuren von 1600
probierten hervor wellen
erfahrungshintergrund und vor allem
erwartungshorizont c entschiedenheit
macht eigentlich viel mehr sehen dass
man in einem geschäft mit wem bezahlt
kriege drinnen bleibt will es gibt
starke nachfrage im prinzip reagieren
die inneren ort die katholische offene
offenen markt sind nutzer chance von
manne markt
1859 setzt sich die sicht von reformator
zwinge überall durch das söldner wesen
wird landesweit verboten
das ist immer so dass wir bis sehr gut
klar aufstieg als bereich
großunternehmen ich muss auf steirische
fpö schlacht wie man muss nicht dem
diversifizieren und so wie es sein
sollte die griechische bank geniki so
dass quasi fritz albrecht ist das cool
prof
und katholik hat dass nino la rosa
gesamt schweizer ich habe bisher stark
soll dienst gehabt die haben noch über
die ganz wirtschaftsstruktur sich bald
wird in euro politisch nichts geändert
hat die richter schlossen post
[Musik]
der mensch trägt die verantwortung für
sein handeln vor sich selbst und vor
gott
so ist es im reformatorischen denken
verankert in konfessionell gemischten
poschiavo entwickeln die menschen daraus
neue ideen
es wird sich auszahlen im achtzehnten
jahrhundert verändert sich für viele das
leben fast von einem tag auf den anderen
der grund dafür liegt hinter den bergen
in venedig die stadt blüht tausende
puschlaver und andere bündner haben hier
arbeit im ausschank und handel mit
kaffee gefunden
bis sie wegen eines handelskrieges
ausgewiesen werden
zurück in poschiavo stehen sie vor dem
nichts
es ist ihre neugier
es ist ihr mut der sie aus der
misslichen situation führen wird
[Musik]
wo der weg versperrt sie sind machen wir
es alternative suchen was handy können
die hände café kennt sie in die tour
bereite der lehrer kennt aber was kann
man damit mache man muss neue nordwinde
die reformierte familie von john an
rimini ist die erste sie verlässt
poschiavo wandert nach warschau aus
eröffnet eine zuckerbäckerei damit
verdient die familie so viel geld dass
sie sich zu hause einen palast leisten
kann
[Musik]
etliche puschlaver folgendem beispiel
weltweit gründen sie zukam bäckereien
etwa das gab es wieder im spanischen
burgos oder das sema den kirchen es ist
ganz einfach tut und dass unser fehler
wie das möglich ist dass sie einfach an
die besten plätze unter mobil fuß vor
warschau dafür könnte eröffnen aber
sicher ist die visitenkarte kaffee tee
in venedig natürlich guten anfang und
mir könnte es einzelne tagebücher briefe
muss der leser es ist einfach arbeit
arbeit arbeit also bis zur
selbstausbeutung sie hemmt tag und nacht
in den cafés krampft damit es auch
funktioniert hätte
mit ihrem desserts in schickem ambiente
brehmes viele zuckerbäcker zu reichtum
[Musik]
daheim in poschiavo verwandeln sie einen
ganzen straßenzug in eine allee von
palästen und sie bringen den fortschritt
ins bergdorf
sie hält planmäßige für die ganze
gemeinschaft gesorgt und hin zum
beispiel sehr frühe show 810 und nachher
ein neues gebäude 825 volksschul für
körper und macht und nachher neue straße
baut das ganze dorf erneuert und sogar
wasser und strom sind da im haus
geliefert worden da viel früher als in
anderen zentren zum beispiel skoda
zürich der fortschritt geht in poschiavo
wie im ganzen bündnerland vornehmlich
auf das konto der reformierten von allen
zucker bäckereien die bündner zwischen
dem achtzehnten und im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert überall auf der welt gründen
gehören 84 prozent protestanten nur 16
prozent gehören katholiken
ob schon die protestanten in der bündner
bevölkerung nur knapp in der mehrzahl
sind
ja
[Musik]
an fronleichnam feiern die puschlaver
katholiken den leib christi reformator
luther hatte diesen feiertag strikt
abgelehnt der konfessionelle graben ist
bis heute augenscheinlich in der
geschichte der zuckerbäcker ist er
geradezu verband entschied dass familien
beliebt für die katholische familie
zentral und sie verlor ich schwierige
und zweitens ist das sich bericht als
erfolg havel cattolica bitter schmeckt
will natürlich alles da ist aufs nächste
leber als das leben danach ausgerichtet
und eigentlich armut tugend hingegen
biete reformierte das reiche von meinem
ziel individuell viel wichtiger
also man hätten direkte kontakt zu gott
individuell nicht durch den priester
also man hat auch in labour das
individuelle selbst stellt felix
mandaten wo man den wirklich machen muss
die zuckerbäcker leisten sich teure
einrichtungen
doch sie sind knallharte rechner
[Musik]
knallhart ist auch die erziehung die
zuckerbäcker schicken ihre kinder ins
ausland in die ausbildung
überlassen sie dort ganz ihrem eigenen
schicksal als lehrling henzi user zu
einer fremden familie lernen und das ist
natürlich erinnere entfernt die die
station zu sehen müsse selber reise sich
verschuldet da für die lange reise nach
spanien nach warschau nach dänemark und
führt lehrzeit händen sich auf das
verschulden und erst wo sie nach dem
diplom hat selber verdienen und den
schulen können ab zahler sind sie als
vollwertige mitglieder vor der kelter
wieder aufgenommen worden
erfolg als oberstes gebot der tisch an
dem die zuckerbäcker einst ihre
einnahmen gezählt haben steht heute
mitten in der reformierten kirche
poschiavo wie ein altar die puschlaver
haben erfolg weil sie
eigenverantwortlich handeln
ganz nach dem willen von luther zwingli
calvin
eine weitere zentrale forderung der
reformatoren jeder soll das alphabet
lernen denn jeder soll die bibel lesen
können
die folgen davon sind kaum zu
überschätzen
im drucker appenzell ausserrhoden prägen
paläste das dorfbild
[Musik]
gebaut von angehörigen der textilhandels
familie sagen sie sind im achtzehnten
und neunzehnten jahrhundert teil der
politischen und wirtschaftlichen elite
des kantons
über mehrere generationen machen sie ein
vermögen im handel mit leinen und
baumwolle der erfolgreichste johannes
zahn ag hirzel ist zu seiner zeit einer
der reichsten schweizer sein credo gute
erziehung und bildung demut und
sparsamkeit sind maßgebend und nie darf
erfolg zu hochmut führen diese
überzeugungen sind schriftlich
überliefert nach dem nachtessen lassen
seine kinder noch ein kapitel im neuen
testament und er betete laut ein gebet
das aus seinem herzen kam er war sehr
sparsam für seine person und familie
heute auch die ausgaben nicht für die
erziehung seiner kinder
für ihn ist bildung das wichtigste
kapital von bestand für seine kinder
sieht er ein leben ohne musik ohne
verschwendung vor da es aber auch
vorgesetzte übertaktete sich also am
morgen sind zustande
denn sofort mit stube hände ein ganz
klar strukturiert die vorgabe cover sind
offen und mütter von nachrichten wohl
nicht ganz in wichtigen aspekten und sie
hat müsse selbst wirksam sind sie halt
'ne taffe ausweichen werde also
ausreichend bestraft worden
alvarez stecken viel geld in die bildung
sie gründen die kantonsschule trogen
ebenso eine armen schule und eine
webschule und sie stecken viel geld in
die örtliche kirche
das korps gemälde zeigt die bewohner der
vier er teile ein zeugnis davon dass ihr
geschäft global betreiben in einer zeit
als ließ alles andere als
selbstverständlich ist war für mich
entscheiden häufig vor der wirtschaft
und die bündig und je im protestantismus
bereich des jahres im katholizismus
dafür hatten die rieder jetzt die
textilien seiner zelle genug dass er
genau 21 bilder gibt das für
spielerinnen ausblickend und das so denn
bessere aber geleistet wird zu handeln
auf ihrem geschäft das ich einfach den
teamgedanken die bildung auch hier teilt
ein tiefer graben reformierte gebiete
von katholischen der blick auf europa
um 1900 haben und portugal spanien und
italien alphabetisierungs quoten
zwischen 25 und 50 prozent
andere katholisch geprägte länder wie
österreich belgien und frankreich kommen
auf gut 80 prozent in den reformierten
niederlanden in finnland großbritannien
deutschland der schweiz und schweden
liegt die quote nahe bei 100 prozent
in schweizer grundschulen liegen die
katholiken zwar nicht mehr zurück weil
sie gute klosterschulen haben und weil
die liberalen schon 1874 die
schulpflicht landesweit durchsetzen
allerdings hochschulen entstehen in
reformierten kantonen dutzende jahre
früher als in katholischen universitäre
bildung wirtschaft und seit dem sieg im
sonderbundskrieg auch die politische
macht alles in den händen der
reformierten sie bauen verkehrswege
zwischen wirtschaftlichen zentren
verleihen diesen noch mehr schub die
prägende figur ist alfred escher gründer
der gotthardbahn der schweizerischen
kreditanstalt der eth und protestant wie
die meisten wirtschaftsführern zwischen
dem achtzehnten und dem zwanzigsten
jahrhundert sind von 100 bedeutenden
schweizer industrie pionieren 84
protestantisch nur gerade elf katholisch
weshalb diese vorherrschaft der deutsche
soziologe max weber schreibt 1905 in
seinem buch die protestantische ethik
und der geist des kapitalismus die
reformatoren seien mit ihrer
neubewertung der arbeit die triebfeder
des modernen kapitalismus gewesen daher
der vorsprung der protestanten ist alles
kompliziert will gesamteuropa stimmt bin
ich ganz gezielt erfolgreiche gebiert
wie zum beispiel adidas ist katholisch
bleiben oder der fragliche gebiet was er
folglich so in katholischen gebieten
regel unter druck kommen ist es nichts
weiter sagen aber was für schweiz tätig
feststellbar ist dass die libri stimmig
geht und dass die stellung zu der arbeit
lohnt sich also sich kritischen wert an
sich und mit 82 zu geld irgendwo liegen
wohl auch bezieher und der hof schaffen
sondern sich in werther und sich und
wenn man erfolgreich ist heißt nicht
dass beruf herz und dass man sich erst
recht wieder strahlen
ich glaube nicht dass der
protestantismus die industrialisierung
direkt bevölkerte aus der max reger
behauptet hat sondern ein katholizismus
den kindern für die interessierte an
dass die investiert er hat andere
möglichkeiten diskutieren
die katholischen gebiete sind um 1900
abgeschlagen ihre ertragsquelle dass
söldner wesen ist weg der industrielle
fortschritt verpasst die macht in den
händen der anderen
sie stehen mit dem rücken zur wand
[Musik]
langsam setzt ein umdenken ein
im hinterthurgau wird die erste
raiffeisen bank gegründet mit ihr soll
auch die katholische landbevölkerung zu
sparen werden
es braucht jahrzehnte bis eine industrie
entsteht wenn fabriken auf katholischen
boden gegründet werden dann oft von
reformierten aber die katholiken legen
ihre gewollte rückständigkeit langsam ab
vor allem ab den 1950 er jahren
ein zweiter wahl kritik dass die
katholische wähler wertewandels
stattfindet als meine ich viel offen
gegenüber technik wissenschaft
wirtschaft karriere in der
privatwirtschaft
wenn der massive ford sich zwei ist
natürlich beeinflusst amerika mit dem
fernseh und mit der allgemeinen
motorisierte zurückführt dass katholiken
immer mehr eine abgeschlossene welt
clapton trennt andere sachen
kennenlernte und hat mit dem rückständig
sehen können wenn jemand das akzeptiere
es rund sowieso
diese einsicht reift auch an der spitze
der katholischen kirche 1965 redet der
papst im zweiten vatikanischen konzil
erstmals offiziell dem fortschritt das
wort jetzt soll alles gefördert werden
technischer fortschritt firmengründungen
die aufgeschlossenheit für das neue
[Musik]
haben sie eigentlich die reformation
kennt er hat glaubte eine damen das
schöne der druckvorstufe modernist
jährige vor der jähriger ist so groß
dass man das zwangsläufigkeit man so
machen hexe nach unten rand in der welt
immer mehr mit der app mit der ablehnung
von fortschritten
auch der zahlenmäßige vorsprung der
renommierten schwindet
aus italien spanien und portugal wandert
einher katholische arbeitskräfte in die
schweiz ein
1970 sind die katholiken in der schweiz
erstmals seit jahrhunderten nicht mehr
in der minderheit
sie erlangen ein neues selbstbewusstsein
[Musik]
klickt waren jetzt wirklich karriere
machen die wirtschaft und der
gesellschaft sehr erfolgreichen mittwoch
plötzlich auf die spitze sind für eine
große und der wärme der eigentlich für
ihren gegründet und das ist schon sehr
niedrig wie im vorjahr
sie erfasst auch die hochfinanz die
schweizerische kreditanstalt von
reformierten gegründet und geführt
erhält 1977 erstmals einen katholischen
chef reiner guth ein katholik auf dem sk
chefsessel
das passt bankintern nicht allen und
wenige jahre davor wäre es undenkbar
gewesen
[Musik]
die katholiken haben ihren rückstand
wettgemacht mehr noch heute sticht
reichtum auch und gerade in einst armen
katholisch bäuerlichen kantonen wie zug
ins auge betrachtet man das
durchschnittliche reinvermögen pro
steuerpflichtigen so liegen heute alle
kantone in etwa gleichauf weit voraus an
der spitze stehen zu schwyz und
nidwalden drei katholische kanton es
scheint die katholiken haben die
reformierten überholt das war ein
oberflächliches sicht wie softie
verhältnis welche richtung ferner
konnten ja nicht letztlich offen die
heimische wirtschaft basis generierte
sich nicht ein industrie und der
wirtschaftspolitik sondern ist
standortpolitik mit dem steuervorteil
funktioniert und insofern ist das
importierte richtung nicht selber
produzierte richtung eines aber zeigen
die zahlen die katholiken haben ihr
verhältnis zu privatem reichtum radikal
verändert katholiken holen auf das ist
die eine hälfte der geschichte die
andere reformierte beginnen gleichzeitig
zu bremsen kritisieren den ungebremsten
fortschritt der wendepunkt serie
prominenz jahrhundertwende vorne
forciert die industrialisierte
unterseite umweltproblem g saite problem
vom ressourcenverbrauch g lampe bruch
und entsprechend heizdecke bewegung hat
sich formiert wo umweltschützer und weil
halt die industrie in der
protestantischen territorial vorjahr ist
die ctc skater bewegt
pioniere gründen nach 1992 und dem bund
für naturschutz die heutige pro natura
gesagt dass es ausschließlich proteste
fast durchschnittlich protestant aktie
sind auch dort tätig sind als präsident
oder twitter mit business schwerpunkte
der stadt basel zürich genf
das ist so verbleiben bis 80er 90er und
die statistiken zeigen laut peter
herrsche auch noch in den 1990 er jahren
haben umweltverbände in reformierten
kantonen bis zu dreimal mehr mitglieder
als in katholischen konfessionelle
gräben auch bei den wahlen bei den
parlamentswahlen 1987 sind unter den
wählern der grünen 63 prozent
protestanten nur gerade 15 prozent
katholiken die reformierten
wirtschaftlich jahrhundertelang voraus
hinterfragen den ungebremsten
fortschritt als erster heute wollen sich
die umweltschutzverbände keiner
konfession zu ordnen
umweltpolitiker bautista glatt knie ist
zwar über die reformierte kirche zur
grünen partei gekommen mittlerweile aber
konfessionslos wie rund ein viertel der
menschen in der schweiz die idee der
reformierten fortschritt skeptiker ist
geblieben
den kompass und wird unter fortschritt
einfach immer mehr verstanden aber nicht
unbedingt bessere lebensqualität und
galt im sinne ersatzreligion worten der
hand wir uns fragen was brauchen wir
überhaupt was ist genug
und das ist viel überfluss und abfall
[Musik]
ob katholisch oder reformiert in der
schweizer wirtschaft ist fortschritt
längst maxime verschwenden ist
rückschritt muse verpönt und der
konfessionelle graben zugeschüttet
[Musik]
konfessionen religionen der heutige
zieht er wieder rolle spiele
es geht vielmehr darum dass es klingt
das umfeld schaffen wo menschen aus ganz
verschiedenen kulturen und für ganz
verschiedene religionen china usa europa
erfolgreich einsamer schafe
wer arbeitet wer erfolg hat ist gut vor
bot vor dem chef vor kollegen luther
zwingli und calvin haben vor 500 jahren
vorgespurt für alle teile der schweiz
[Musik]
das natürlich nicht als konfession
zurückführe das ist klar aber mit wer
viele wirtschaftshistoriker das ist
vielleicht flugzeug sieht das ist die
globen sportlichkeit will wenn die
genossenschaft konfessionell homogen
werk blieben chancen viel größer sie
dass sie sich beeilt oder der andere
europäische großmacht angeschlossen hat
und so allenfalls die großen
europäischen krieg verwickelt wurde
einst im roman paul die konfession mit
man glaubt da die griechen benutzt und
das hat natürlich schon bei der zweiten
relativ tolerant sind zu beklagen dass
es auch andere möglichkeiten geld
zurückzuholen
wie sind wir gut und vor wem
[Musik]